[Music]
most of our madam but one Bonanza base
here the bottom arrival may have sealed
about presence just we reveal the enemy
setna account havoc with you Alan
Bernstein key please - of the direction
the nests you can achieve the relevancy
computer appetite registry turn after
dr. Dallas tomorrow so no sake that
means the ratio for more than 30 years
safar has been connecting Canada's and
the world's best researchers we bring
them together into collaborative
interdisciplinary programs and ask them
to tackle questions of importance to the
world our researchers have made
important discoveries in areas as
diverse as population health the
genetics of disease artificial
intelligence and the beginning of the
universe today safar has 360 researchers
from all over the world grouped together
in 14 different interdisciplinary
programs CFR plays an important role not
only in advancing knowledge but in
sustaining Canada's global research
leadership just be particular maroudo
Vata dosha Emilio De La Rochelle Quebec
knew so many Unisa SWAPO syllable
Italians as you see at speak particulary
Shasha
Bozzio Quebec set off a lava god the
percy module many people in the room
tonight have worked hard to make these
successes possible and among them are
the members of CFR's Board of Directors
in fact CFR held its board meeting here
in Montreal today so we have a number of
Directors in attendance tonight and I'd
like to take a moment to introduce each
one of them and as I call your name my
friend directors could you please stand
Jim dinning David dodge Jets go Brenda
Eaton Lindsay Gordon Stephen Lister Pat
Meredith Bruce Mitchell Lawrence
Pentland barb stymies our chair and Bill
Young
[Applause]
and thank you all for your tireless work
which is so vital to sustaining CFR for
decades to come
Oh filled a soiree Zachariah FA Aisha is
lucre in a travail confess awake a month
cause egg baptized vatra table CFR has
been undergoing significant
transformation in recent years and the
driving force behind this has been its
president and CEO Alan Bernstein dr.
Alan Bernstein has spearheaded a
dramatic new vision for the organization
among other things he instituted a
global call for ideas that led to a 25%
expansion in its research portfolio
Alan has also increased the Institute
focus on connecting researchers with
those in medical practice or policy
making or industry who can turn
knowledge and insights into actions that
have impact on our world eagle Missoula
guven darlin growl socially research $1
for SEO is really new savaris AMA
restrict jewelry not riparian destiny Oh
John chapter insomnia and Argan Zephyr
on with serene Iran des expert modular
ashesh Sala be a nitrogen alpha Q nom de
Ville sighs Alan ed will see a chef
Sharky approved do surveys and
publications Vic selective iki effete a
contribution
epic town and its hood the salute suit
each cancer related director-general a
global HIV vaccine enterprise a please
default attire there's a psychology the
research on salty he is a senior fellow
of Massey College and is an Officer of
the Order of Canada
last year he was inducted into the Cajun
Medical Hall of Fame Javadoc au lait dr.
Allen Bernstein mercy junkie and thank
you for your very nice introduction and
your opening remarks and for the work
you do for forsee far it's really
wonderful to be in Montreal tonight and
I think this is a great follow up on a
long but very exciting day that we had
at our board meeting here in Montreal
Gemma Raymond Tanakh boots wet de la
Bienvenue assets soiree Newsome Ravi
d'etre premier ozc
am Arielle kebbel sweet on journey Irish
on discuss Joan this is I think truly an
extraordinary time in science from last
month exciting discovery of
gravitational waves which Vicki Kaffee
might tell you about which provided the
very first experimental evidence of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
to crispr cast nine technology which is
genome editing and has the power to
detect if you will a single letter
mistake in a 900-page book and to
correct it to artificial intelligence
which I'm sure Yahshua we'll talk about
later on tonight and smart cars the pace
of science has been extraordinary
extending humanity's understanding of
the world around and in us and the
cosmos in which we live now when I was a
boy I dreamt of sitting in the front row
of the Montreal Forum to watch Beliveau
and rock had Rashard and Gila Fleur play
hockey of course unfortunately that
dream never came no I'm still a boy at
heart that only buddy wants to correct
that mistake but but today is president
of CFR I truly have the privilege of
having the very best seat in the house
to watch the very best scientists in the
world do what they do best
which is to advance our understanding of
ourselves the society we create the
world around us and the cosmos that we
inhabit and from that understanding we
know from the past 300 years of science
will come better wealthier healthier and
more fulfilled lives so tonight all of
you I'll have a front seat seated at
most of our tables is a CFR board member
and a thief our fellow and so I hope
you'll take the opportunity to discuss
with our board members where the
Institute is now headed and with our
researchers how CFR contributes to the
research that they do and their views of
where science is going
I'm also especially delighted to extend
a special welcome to the as really
Foundation and to the family this is
really and dr. ezra le who are in the
audience here with us this evening
through the as reallys foundations
greatests a great support the largest
gift CFR has ever received in our 34
year history
[Applause]
we have been able to significantly
enhance one of our new research programs
and to launch just last week the new CFR
s really global Scholars Program a very
exciting new program for young
scientists which were both very excited
about I'd also like to acknowledge many
other generous donors that are here with
us this evening I can't sing a lot
everybody but I will sing a lot the
Power Corporation the trache Family
Foundation and the Howard Webster
foundation I believe that we live in a
time when organizations like CFR are
needed more than ever it is research and
research alone that gives us hope and
can address the complexity and the
magnitude of today's opportunities and
their challenges climate change the
refugee crisis that we see all too often
on our TV screens terrorism social
inclusivity economic development child
and brain development the health of our
oceans the genetic basis of disease all
of these challenges and many more they
demand the collaborative effort of the
world's very best researchers regardless
of discipline regardless of institution
regardless of country and that is
precisely what CFR does for more than 30
years we have been connecting Canada and
the world's best minds in unique global
research programs to address questions
of importance to the world there is no
other organization like C far we give
our fellows and advisers who are based
in a hundred and fifteen institutions in
eighteen countries the time and the
freedom to explore new perspectives new
collaborations and explore new paths to
discovery and paradigm shifts and ways
of thinking C far creates the unique
conditions that make it possible for our
fellows in widely divergent fields to
have deep conversations to learn from
each other and to
with each other over time our fellows
shape entirely new ways of understanding
and you will see three I believe
outstanding examples tonight
our work puts Canada at the very center
of the world's most important global
conversations and those conversations
ultimately lead to transformative
knowledge that will change the world
CFR makes Canada's best better
throughout CFR's history Quebec has been
an integral part of our success
Quebec of course is as a strong has a
strong dynamic center of Canadian
research I can cite lots of people I
won't start that Brenda is Brenda Milner
here she was on the guest list maybe
she's not a right brenda of course a
world famous neuroscientist in her well
into her 90s now at the mni for over 20
years we have had key fellows from the
Quebec research community at sea far
among those I'd like to acknowledge in
particular our Pierre 4/10 who I saw
earlier this evening
there you are Pierre professor of
economics at the University to come back
on Montreal
girag bouche our distinguished historian
and social scientists at the university
do Quebec I should CUDA me and atonium
Ione a political scientist at McGill
University and recently appointed Dean
of Arts at McGill who serves as a member
of the president's Research Council 31
of our fellows and advisors come from
Quebec and three of them service
directors of our research programs and
conversely CFR brings to Quebec the
opportunity to work within close knit
interdisciplinary groups where they can
build collaborations with the best minds
in the world our researchers come from
top international institutions like
Harvard Princeton Oxford Stanford the
London School of Economics the occult
Polytechnique and many others see far
has a long history of partnerships in
the province of Quebec our current
fellows hail from McGill the université
de montréal Laval University the Quebec
Amar'e al University to Quebec Asha kuda
me Concordia and the University this
Sherbrooke I like to single out the
university of sherbrooke as an example
of the synergy between CFR and our
university partners the Department of
Physics there is one of the strongest in
Canada fully half of the members of its
physics department are in CFR programs
either in quantum materials or in
quantum information science
Luigi I fir distinguished physicist who
you'll hear from later this evening has
been the director of our program in
quantum materials and AC far fellow
since 1992 and a physics professor and
canada research chair at Sherbrooke
since 2002 for more than two decades see
far has been connected to the research
effort at Sherbrooke helping that
university recruit talent and build a
critical mass of expertise in quantum
science that investment received an even
greater boost from the Canada first
research excellence fund the new federal
government program through which the
federal government of awarded thirty
three and a half million dollars for
research in quantum science at
Sherbrooke
now see far has two other mandates the
first is the second is to support the
next generation of research leaders and
this month as I've said we launched the
new C FRS really global Scholars Program
that program will bring together
outstanding early career researchers
from around the world and connect them
with the world's best in our research
networks it's a tremendous opportunity
for young researchers at the very
beginning of their careers to launch
their careers - to be able to interact
with the world's best in their fields of
study we also work to connect our
fellows with stakeholders who can
benefit from that work we regularly now
hold briefings with senior government
officials so they can learn directly
from some of the most informed
researchers in the world and we're
organizing similar opportunities for
leaders in industry community service
health care and more I was very pleased
with a discussion that we had earlier
today with CFR's Borg which reaffirmed
its desire to see CFR expand its role in
convening the best minds in the world
not just in research but also in policy
and practice and with this we believe we
are accelerating the ability for that
knowledge and the insights generated by
our researchers to have truly great
impact on the world you know Louis
Pasteur once said what every researcher
wants is just two things he wants to
make a great discovery and he wants that
discovery to benefit mankind and that's
what we expect of our 365 researchers
so tonight we will hear from three
outstanding Quebec based CFR fellows who
are not only among the best in Canada
but they are amongst the best in the
world first we'll hear from Louie ty for
his research into the quantum properties
of materials could lead to room
temperature super conductivity and more
efficient power transmission from yoshua
bengio from the université de montréal
about how artificial intelligence
developed within the CFR program that he
called that he leads will give rise to
smart cars and props new ways of
discovering new medicines and many other
applications from viki Casspi about
changes to what we know about how our
universe was formed and how it is shaped
today donítí ryeong our vp research and
partnerships will introduce these three
distinguished researchers to you later
on this evening to do all that we do we
depend critically on the generosity of
our supporters I'd like to thank the
federal and provincial governments of
Quebec of Ontario of Alberta British
Columbia and the federal government for
their support and the donors whose names
you I think will see on the screen this
evening many are here tonight and I'm
grateful to you for making our research
possible and of course I've seen all the
some of them
it is now my very great pleasure to
introduce dr. Roman Curia Remi is
Quebec's first chief scientist in that
very important role he advises the
minister of higher education research
and science
maintaining Quebec's position as a true
leader in research at home and abroad
he also chairs the three phone to
research to Quebec the boards and is a
valued member of CFR president Research
Council for me is an eminent scientist
in his own right who has made many
contributions to our understanding of
Alzheimer's disease and mental health in
fact as I recall her me the very first
thing I said to you was you publish too
much
[Laughter]
over me is a member of the Royal Society
of Canada the Order of Canada and the
art Nationale du Quebec
as well as the 2003 recipient of the
Wilder Penfield price amongst many other
honors and most importantly he is a
friend and former colleague from our
time battle Institute they were sure
Sean T to Canada his support and advice
has been invaluable to the Institute
once again I want to thank every one of
you for coming here this evening and for
your support and I hope you've enjoy
hope you will enjoy your evening
now please join me in welcoming dr. emir
yoma bonsoir
merci beaucoup Alan Bienvenue a truly
mom of course a demonstration liquor
behavior a truly associate electrical
signal Italian accent associate ecard we
press combination Oh silly John Sheridan
Assad associate Erica prima as important
to see every year a very messy a car for
the shop or a donkey sulphate sweetie la
Bienvenue au nong bua anima Quebec no
Minister Nouveau no Minister Minister
dual economy relations innovation
la Mina's Madame Dominic are glad you
see chambers patella be a new you know
the law a minister who can on a pattern
a Cal Chrisman Minister the last segment
spiria
a lemon is Aryan David McCune only do
mini so you know the font or she'll do
connect hermano personnel behave new
sefa
well I think Adam mentioned a few quite
a few things but for me what resonate is
excellence excellence and excellence
this is number one partnership number
two mentoring number 3 c2 demo so to FA
associate now let me see the front of a
shared living memory Sudanese as well a
present director switched from Santa Ana
do bad stuff that can adults believe it
Aurora don't pour new found Rochelle's
Quebec come Polycarp like surrounds but
come for me affair as a Susheela becomes
a team ASEAN apparel on québécois given
pretty certain the Rizzuto a shells
don't calculate see certain mark to meet
Lee mayor Sonora mayor among partnership
that's part of my mandate try to do
partnership for the font of a shelter
Quebec with various ministry in Quebec
various organization in Quebec various
organization in Canada and various
organizations globally that's part of
the mandate and I always tell the
colleague Quebec basically kind of a
suburb of Beijing in terms of population
if we want to have impact we have to
partner and we have to partner with the
best in the world then for us see far is
among the very best in the world at the
moment I think Alan was very polite not
to say that but I'd say it at the moment
the partnership is small from the
founder of Quebec we are a partner with
sefa but we really need to build on
when we compare what the federal
government is doing what Ontario is
doing and others I know there is someone
from the cabinet here of Dominica glad
my repulsions and so certainly we'll be
able to talk a little bit more about
that in the coming weeks mentoring poor
new front of a shelter Quebec of young
Karen person tyranny
the pellagra relationship completely
matura it's a fake associate of a critic
donk the new hope I am because Emma
Reseda meeting new foster care programs
Allen already mentioned the partnership
in the context of the large federal
program with the University - a book I
think in the phase - and there's many
people here from University Moran from
Polytechnic from share broke and
foremothers the role that that sefa
played in the preparation of the
application that was submitted just few
days ago was amazing and they I would
like to thank my friend Anita he really
was very much involved with the
university in Quebec to try to build a
proposal that would be highly
competitive nationally and
internationally and maybe I should not
say it but I said no even for those of
you in the room vp research even if it's
not a proof your submission to the
program at the federal level will do it
anyway all the work that you put into
that so working with CFO and working
with us at the PhotoShelter Quebec and
kept a government will deliver and I'm
very happy that in the end the
government said yes we're ready to write
very strong letter of support to put
money on the table and they did more I
will say then I expected personally so
that extremely extremely good news so I
really wish you a very very good night
you are great science and I look forward
to working more
closely in the future with CFR and all
of you you'll see you made nasty that
and of all I knew it sir old SP then
they walk on Niigata pamaj pauletta sigh
ah sure sure except C&L the sharky
sharky gone literally is out three
exceptional leaders all of them
directors of CFR programs which means
that they are leading international
teams of a top scientists in the world
in their area and there are many team
leaders in this crowd tonight so you
know that this really means something
this young Vicki transformer Lamond
dedicated levy say the rack'em O'Keefe
only go see some liquor and I will say
this in English because this is very
important
these people are see far without them
see far as no resonator and as long as
we attract in our organization people of
that caliber we have a role to play and
if ever we stop attracting that kind of
people then for us at the end so that's
very simple
the first one will be wit I fire
director of the program very closely
material Quantic investiture book Alan
was a courtier proto-tool whole la la
acción special exist Cherokee Nikola so
unique Oh Canada
yeah Salinas Takeo Ricci is Raziel
please the FS only present elegant a
lapras strategic loot seeker present
liquor for develop a
Roger devotion book Louie is director of
the program on quantum materials the
expression quantum materials which is
known all around the world today was
actually invented by this program this
did not exist the world quantum
materials until the group started
talking about this LabVIEW graffitied we
could of national Quebec odds Canada
please Kay Beckman Victor ring let me
die yes bear the producer - Abu Anas
auteur prefers Kuwait see African may
matter with high five Messi denis.df
knew a tooth danuel across my home Safed
pavetta Jeff a passage program so meta
aquatic we selected plastic or metal
Quonset missiny come down energy no
material core technique just a Beretta
lavoy Avanti amid no truly short fix our
cases say a 40 the resulting material
all appropriate electronics or a
particular a potato mayor exam the sauce
see the super conductivity don't really
palaces for so a superconductor is a
metal that when you cool it when you
cool it down it undergoes a phase
transition a very abrupt
sudden phase transition as displayed
here where the resistance as a function
of temperature the resistance to
electric current goes abruptly to zero
and it's exactly zero so the only
formula I'm asking you to remember
today is our equals zero very simple so
R is really absolutely zero meaning that
the conduction of electricity is perfect
so conductivity is is infinite so the I
mean these words of perfect infinite are
rare in nature but in this case this is
really the case so much so that if you
have an electric current going around a
loop just a wire and you take off the
battery and you just close the loop that
current will go on forever
well technically I think it we estimated
a hundred thousand years
that's perpetual motion this sort of
almost magical property of
superconductors has actually been been
applied in real technology so today the
app the main applications are
electromagnets
powerful electromagnets that enable
things like MRI imagery magnet signal
Tito let me test you on the train come
down a maglev mula deflection the past
you'd better make a sale but there may
be other applications the US Department
of Energy estimates that by 2030 the
demand on electricity in the US will go
up by 50 percent globally by a hundred
percent these are enormous increases for
a system that almost a capacity so it is
felt that something some kind of
revolution has to happen if if that
demand would be met some people think
that that revolution will come from
superconductors a few years ago
Scientific American went through a next
interesting exercise in trying to come
up with 12 really big events that would
change everything so they they mentioned
machine intelligence which will hear
about dimensions human cloning
they mentioned of course things like
total nuclear warfare polar meltdown
asteroid hits the planet deadly pandemic
you know the more boring ones and then
room-temperature superconductors why
didn't they put it up there precisely
for this reason that if you have that
the whole grid which the Association of
American engineers regards as the the
single most important technological
advance of the 20th century the electric
grid that will be revolutionized now the
problem is that superconductors today is
strictly limited to low temperatures
it's a low temperature phenomena we only
have superconductivity at very low
temperatures here I'm drawing the
critical temperature below which you see
super conductivity as a function of
years so it was discovered in 1911
sateda kuvera dollmaker
Moffatt cut degree Kelvin or cut the
Grissom was also some price Celsius
press f1 on that ASA temperature is
nearly killed yeppeo filly the knee
bones are motile sperm epub and then
came a revolution in 1986 the fastest
ever awarded Nobel Prize for that
discovery in money within one year 1987
for a family of materials where the
critical temperature shot up by a factor
7 within a few years and then
frustratingly it stopped at halfway to
room temperature you see this bar there
at 150 that's halfway to room
temperature that family of materials are
sort of saturated there since then so
the question is how can we improve on
that and from the perspective of a
scientist a research scientist the
question really is going back to the
microscopic principles of what causes
supersonic so at the microscopic level
of electrons moving around in
metal super conductivity is about the
binding of electrons into pairs it's
sort of counterintuitive but it's not
very well understood that two electrons
can pair if they'll if they're able to
polarize the solid around them so they
have a negative charge they polarize the
positively charged ions and that can
then bring about another electrons that
follows and therefore forms of pairs so
let's call this the electric force it's
the conventional force that's very well
understood in fact now in 2008 sorry
discovery was made so you know eight
years ago of a new family of
superconductors so not the copper base
that I mentioned but now iron based
superconductors and in those materials
it was very clear that a new force is at
play not the conventional electric force
that we know and understand well that
works at minus 250 degrees but something
that works actually at higher
temperatures so you see in this diagram
here this is called a phase diagram so
we have temperature on the y-axis and
concentration of electrons on there on
the x axis this is something you can
change by tuning the chemistry and on
the left you have a face that's magnetic
so what do we mean by that we mean like
the the bar magnet on your fridge that's
a magnet so this is a state that
electrons can enter into so there we
have a magnetic phase if you go a little
bit to the right then we have a
superconducting phase and
superconductivity Peaks where the
magnetic phase ends and that's a key
that's the key to tell us that actually
the super conductivity comes from a
magnetic force it's actually it's not
the sort of electric polarizability or
susceptibility of the material that is
important it's the magnetic
susceptibility that's important so the
magnetic force has been established in
these family of materials and it's
giving a TC that's significant very hot
still very cold
more perspective but high from the
perspective of superconductors just two
years ago another discovery and the same
family of materials was made this is
very simple material iron selenium but
people found out a group of scientists
in China found out that if you make a
single atomic layer of this stuff and
you stick it on top of a substrate you
can double TC and they achieved 100
Kelvin this is this caused a sensation
and the understanding we have at the
moment is that actually they're
combining the two forces the magnetic in
the thin film Fe se and the electric in
the more conventional substrate that
seem to work together the boost to get
that factor of 2 last year a striking
discovery that in just about the
simplest material you can think of
hydrogen which is a gas as we know if
you pressurize that gas and turn it into
a solid for this you need pressures that
are comparable to the pressure inside
the earth huge pressures only a few labs
in the world can do this if you
pressurize hydrogen gas actually
technically it's a ch3 yes it's hydrogen
sulfide but it's a gas of hydrogen if
you pressurize it you make it a metal it
becomes a superconductor and not only
that where it's the best ever
superconductors we have 200-gallon this
is two thirds of the temperature you
know so we there's an excitement at the
moment there's a sense where it is
possible to have a room-temperature
superconductor and so let me just
mention one discovery made by Seif our
team very recently in 2015 was published
in 2016 I'm going back now to our copper
based superconductors which hold the
record at least at room pressure you
don't have to apply enormous pressures
and here you see a phase diagram that
sort of looks like the phase diagram I
showed you before where you have no
temperature and concentration but the
magnetic phase ends before the
superconducting phase begin so it's
different and in fact what's been the
mystery in that field for the last 20
years is this thing marked with a
question mark this some other phase we
call it the pseudo gas phase but you
know might as well call it a dark face
or so so what the hell is that face
there's a lot of debate and and what the
c14 finally did and i was enabled by a
development in produced in the
production of very large magnetic fields
is that they used a huge magnetic field
to kill superconductivity to wipe it out
and then go and look at zero temperature
or very very close to zero temperature
to identify the signature of the
critical point where that mysterious
phase ends and that's just been done and
that gives us a new window on basically
what's going on where the
superconductivity is strongest and we
feel we have hold on what is likely to
be the force at play here and all we
need is a factor of two so that team
just will tell you a little bit how CFR
has played a key role in this discovery
as in many others is it is because of
this chart it's because in our field of
material science you need three kinds of
experts you need people who make
materials and these are like modern-day
alchemists they're people they're
geniuses who who combine atoms and make
new materials all the time so you need
people who make materials then you need
people measure those the properties of
those materials and there's many
properties you can imagine measuring you
can shine light you can shine you can
apply large magnetic fields large
pressures low temperatures measure
electrical properties and so on right so
you need this experimentalists on the
incircle number two here finally you
need theorists who develop theories and
model to really have a mathematical
understanding of what's going on and and
the key is to close that loop tightly
and to have the best in the world work
together on the long-term basis wherever
they're from and they're they're very
likely not to be in the same place and
not even to be in Canada all of them so
you might have a Japanese myth
expert and an American theorist with the
Canadian experimental team so the keys
to bring these people together and
that's really what see far does and so
in this particular discovery I can
mention that the groups that were
involved were a group of materials
experts recognizes the best in the field
at UBC pairing up with our team at
Sherbrooke doing the experiments with
one guy called serial post in in
Toulouse who's the best the best
scientist for high field measurements so
to lose the Toulouse National Lab has
recently made a 90 Tesla magnet is right
there and 90 Tesla is just above the
highest field you can produce and there
was two thousand two million times the
Earth's magnetic field so they've only
had that for a year this guy is the best
guy to operate it and we he's been a
member for ten years of our program so
that team came together to enable that
discovery okay so where do we go from
here well we need to understand what's
just been discovered more so more
measurements are needed the theorists
need to then model that and predict what
knob to turn to access to get that
factor of two and then deliver that that
mandate to the materials guys when the
NR gonna have to make the materials that
superconductor at room temperature it
could be some kind of a substrate some
kind of film deposit they probably a
combination of film and substrate for
example so just to summarize then I
would I foresee a bright future for
superconductivity I've mentioned in
particular how it could revolutionize
the grid and that here I'm showing an
electric car because if all cars go
electric in the next 20 years
imagine the increase on the demand of
electricity it's going to be enormous
that wasn't factored in to the deal we
estimate of 50 percent that's one
example of green energy but you know we
might think of others like Solar
androgens
Aurra that you'd like to bring to Europe
at the moment you know high-power line
high-frequency lines or not are not a
solution you need a DC superconducting
pipeline underneath the Mediterranean to
do it for example so enabling of green
energies is one thing quantum computing
madly might be involved the quantum
computer is the big holy grail of
another program at CFR and many
proposals are on the table but one of
the promising ones is a superconducting
qubit as the basis for a superconducting
computer and finally just an analogy I'd
like to make because my gut feeling is
that we cannot actually imagine what the
room-temperature superconductors really
do it's a little bit like the transistor
you know in 1947 when it was invented
people were asked ok so what's that
gonna do for us Wow they had no idea
right the Google 60 years later right so
you have no idea so the same I think
will happen if you have a
room-temperature superconductor and the
the analogy I like to make is between
electricity and light you know you can
have a 100 watt light bulb and you can
have a 100 watt laser you immediately
know that there's something special
about the laser it can manipulate
information in a very focused way and
that's because of something called
quantum coherence which means that all
the particles in this case photons are
doing the same thing they have the same
wavelength nearly the same phase you
want that coherence well a
superconductor is a quantum coherent
form of electricity and we don't have
that at the moment we have it at very
low temperatures when we have it at room
temperature on your table I think a lot
of bright young minds will find ways to
use them so I trust in that and so let
me close by saying that repeating a
little bit was Alan said that we've just
started created a new Institute in
Sherbrooke called the quantum Institute
who would have guessed and that comes in
the wake of a major award from the
federal government that came through
this new program called the Canada first
research excellence fund whose inaugural
competition was last year so him
very unusual thing I mean the federal
government has you know several billion
dollars to offer it launches a
competition one project per university
60 projects were submitted five were
selected two out of those five are in
quantum materials you might ask well why
the answer is C far the reason why those
two won at UBC one at Sherbrooke the
reason why they won the reason why they
got hundred million dollars to do
quantum materials research for the next
seven years is because of C far because
the correct one of the important
criteria is whereas how well are you
connected to the world Wow we only had
to say C for that was a demonstration so
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
what can I say NASA we do is employ
vitro's a leap yoshua bengio director
co-director reprogrammed the liquor
s'appelle apparatus our automatic
apparatus our Buick Joshua a professor I
didn't just in Moorea with a partner
Monday from 8c Competizione you know I
take for granted that you have all heard
of Internet in this room see far has
nothing to do with that maybe not all of
you have heard about deep learning sea
far as a lot to do with deep learning
that's a new paradigm for making
intelligent effective use of computer
data in vision and speech and image
recognition in natural language
processing deep learning has completely
revolutionized the world of IT and the
last small number of years two or three
years and that is recognized all around
the world as having been a sea far
enterprise in just a few years the
volume of business associated to deep
learning has gone from the $1,000,000
per year that CFR was putting in this
program to several today several
billions of dollars the roshanda metal
such as ball mounts of Criminology
Yahshua are the cat eye he saw a Cecila
kic on the deep learning cisterna
colossus the point opinion
Internacional avec Jeff Fenton a young
[ __ ] Joshua potato a particularity that
was so weak Joshua Z the Demery that
amount academic make a really poor dog
comes with many quality of I poor
transferee
on the dark side he talks about
monocular academic deep learning a
sitter program key mount the fast song
exactly comma the amount of a shared
among the technology servers winema
modern EP comically large man a
transformation o de la planète Suffolk -
apart see the labels the lessons
yoshua bengio
[Applause]
Macedonia math simple set introduction
welcome everybody I'm gonna tell you
about AI I'm gonna tell you about deep
learning effect [ __ ] Haruko State
Department blah
Luciana Montana tell me deep learning we
ended the neutrogenia journey is st. M
key
Prine + key to Obama please know to
attend neural networks you may have
heard about neural networks and
basically deep learning is the modern
way of neural networks ok so let me move
on about about deep learning so what is
this about
first I need to tell you a little bit
about AI how do we make intelligent
machines an intelligent entity whether
it's human or a machine needs knowledge
and where is that knowledge is gonna
come from what we've discovered in the
last few years and is that to give
knowledge to computers we just let the
computers learn from data learn from
examples in this this very simple idea
has worked beyond expectations in the
last couple of decades and deep learning
is the most recent instantiation of this
which is extremely successful it has
yielded breakthroughs first in speech
recognition then in computer vision and
now ongoing in natural language
understanding and we're working on
health applications and many others
around the world so let me try to tell
you more first of all a little bit of
the history so here are the three
musketeers
it was Kataya dont denie parlez-vous
replicas met Geoff Hinton ow
Jeff is reka de Marissa program de
Dycker
and just don't - the song says fuzzy and
put sodium or Aldo on to New York the
three of us were working on this
Challenge we didn't know before 2006 how
to make these neural networks deeper how
to have more layers and and thanks to
the use of unsupervised learning some
some new way of doing things we for the
first time ten years ago we managed to
to pass this bear and then and then in
later years we found other tricks and
and lots of researchers embarked on this
and then applications came years later
one thing I want to mention is that it's
because CFR believed in us believed in
in an area which 10 years ago was
considered not promising not fashionable
but that see far and and and a few other
people in our group of course believed
could change the world
that this happened it's bigger because
we collectively made these bets because
we believed in this fundamental research
which you know it wasn't clear where it
would go that we are today with the
amazing applications that we'll be
telling you about and it's just the tip
of the iceberg was going to come laters
is much more important ok so it started
after our our scientific advances which
have continued at a pretty slow pace
we've started to see the impact in
industry and one of the first areas was
speech recognition I don't know if you
ever remember using phone systems with
speech recognition
it was terrible right and nowadays it
just works if you have the right systems
with most of the systems are pretty good
now it even works a much ma'am I've ha
say ok
since my marsupial concealer like a
subprocess time to organize of the power
the Anto in I was expecting it would not
work because there's not nearly as much
data for French as for English miss a
function a memory to subduct sunset I
don't yo copy
well DP the kooky big wah so
interestingly this happened after about
10 years of stagnation of performance so
this curve shows over years the accuracy
the error right sorry of speech
recognition systems and the little white
circle is when deep-learning got into
the picture right the next breakthrough
came in computer vision actually
computer vision is in a sense much
bigger than speech recognition because
vision is such an important sense for us
and for understanding the world and it
came with two important ingredients
beyond what we had done for speech
recognition and these are very simple
things
computing power and data the computing
power came thanks to GPUs graphics
processing units unity GPU kyouda
paranoid mu point police video is to
suffer some tribal leaders would Noorani
pool image because on that risk is his
keep on deposit on calculate the other
big element was data
thanks to crowdsourcing we were able to
label lots more data and it turned out
to be to be very important and so in the
span of three or four years since then
the error rate has gone down so that on
several benchmarks we're now essentially
at the same level as human performance
which I you know I couldn't have
believed that just a few years ago
so this as of course attracted a lot of
attention from the media it started
about 2012 and not only the media
quickly big companies like Google and
Facebook realize that this could be very
very
for them and and they started fighting
to to buy talent to by my colleagues
Jeff and Leon and to buy companies like
deepmind
a British company which had basically a
couple two dozen PhDs with deep learning
expertise mostly coming from our labs
and not making any money but you know
they bought it for five hundred million
pounds actually and then of course a lot
of other companies jumped in and some
were already there like IBM and
Microsoft and many other came in to this
including nowadays companies like
welcome who want to build chips so the
thing we've seen with GPUs is nothing
when they start building specialized
hardware to run these neural nets we're
going to be able to cram a lot more
knowledge into these these machines so
let me say a few words about why deep
learning is is is working the the
central idea is to learn representations
the classical machine learning is going
directly from inputs to classifications
predictions the thing that we want the
system to perform these these neural
nets and especially the deep ones they
introduce intermediate levels of
representations and we can try to
understand what these do so in the
picture here each little square
represents what a particular artificial
neuron likes and we see these three
levels on a lower level the these
artificial neurons like to detect edges
and images and higher up we have units
that like to recognize parts of your
face like part of a nose or an eye and
in this these are obtained by combining
the detection is made at the lower level
and then again higher up we see units
that like to detect particular kinds of
faces and they combine the parts
together and that's just one of the ways
but the important idea is that there's
this compositionality in other words
composing pieces together and that gives
what computer scientists love which is
an exponential advantage and so one of
the things we've proven recently is that
you
you can represent very rich functions by
by doing a series of these
transformations extracting these these
detectors that are learned you can
represent functions that are more
abstract in some sense and that's what
allows these machines to generalize
better to new cases which is what we
want machine learning to do another nice
thing about thinking in terms of
representations is that we can play very
fun games so instead of just thinking
about representing an image we can think
about representing different kinds of
things like images but also text or
speech or any kind of information and in
this example which is google image
search what they've done is they're
learning a representation for queries
for for sequence of characters which is
in the same space as a representation
for images so they're learning two
transformations two functions one that
goes from an image to these hundred
numbers representing the the semantic
content of the image and they also learn
a function it goes from from a sequence
of characters through the same hundred
numbers such that things that mean the
same thing that talk about the same
topic end up close to each other so
Dolphin will be mapped to something
close to the image of a dolphin and
other images of dolphins even though
they might look different will end up
near each other and that's how they are
able to answer your queries and find
images that mean something that's
related to what you typed and of course
you could go in the other direction and
give it an image you can find sequences
of characters that have a similar
meaning one of the things we've done in
my lab in particular is combine this
representations for images and
representations for natural language and
one of the most impressing impressive
recent results we obtained is having a
system that takes an image as input and
produces a sentence in English so here
you see on the left this image of a
woman in the park and the computer
produces the words
a woman is throwing a frisbee in a park
what you see in the second image is
where the computer is putting its
attention while it's saying the
underlined word so here when it's saying
frisbee it's actually paying attention
to the the part of the image that
contains the frisbee in the second image
it's seeing this image with a dog and
it's saying a dog is standing on a
hardwood floor and when it says dog it's
it's it's looking at the image of the
dog right now it still makes a lot of
mistakes because we didn't have that
much data to train it so you can see
some of the examples of mistakes which
are very informative and helps us to
understand you know how to improve these
systems so for example the second one
you see this image of a woman and the
computer says a woman holding a clock in
her hand so obviously it's a mistake
there is no clock but if you look at the
the pattern on her shirt when the
computer says clock it's it's actually
looking at that pattern it's like
circular and there are some letters
there so you could confuse it for a
clock right sometimes it makes really
crazy statements like for the third one
it says a man wearing a hat and a hat on
a skateboard well I have no idea where
this is coming from but if you train it
with a lot more data then you can get
these kinds of results there's a video
so now the computer is there a baby he's
gonna answer our questions yes what is
the man doing typing is the baby sitting
on his lap yes what you see are this are
they smiling the main answer is by
scoring answers that it finds is there a
baby in the photo yes where is the baby
standing bathroom
what is the baby doing brushing teeth
what game is being played soccer is
someone kicking the ball yes
what color is the ball yellow what game
is the dog playing second answer was
green frisbee what color is the dog
black is the dog wearing a color yes
what is the cat sniffing banana where's
the cat on bed what color is the cat
black and white what color are the
bananas green all right let's now let me
tell you a few words about where this is
leading us and one of the hottest areas
right now is to go beyond the
traditional pattern recognition ability
of these systems and into higher-level
condition and we're still making baby
steps so what you're see here is these
recurrent neural Nets special kinds of
neural nets that are able to read a
piece of text and answer a question but
this time the answer is not obvious and
you have to reason you have to combine
multiple facts together so let me read
this to you the computer reads this some
Sam walks into the kitchen Sam picks an
apple Sam walks into the bedroom sub
drop some drops the Apple where is the
Apple well if you follow what I said you
should know that it's in the bedroom
and in it you know you can't just look
for words that are names of places
because you could say kitchen as well
right so so some kind of reasoning is
necessary now I'm gonna show you a video
of showing again these kinds of image to
text translation that's been done at
Facebook from my co-director Yann Luca
and you'll see something pretty pretty
nice for blind people who can now get a
sense of what
in images
[Music]
our goal is to build intelligent
machines to help people in their daily
lives what makes us intelligence is our
ability to learn and this is what we are
trying to reproduce in machines to some
extent we get inspiration from biology
what we can do with current technology
is build networks of simulated neurons
on the order of magnitude of the brain
of a mouse they say so the way we train
our machine will show the bunch of
images of segment of dogs and for each
image we tell it what it is to
information to be able to learn to
perform the tasks the more we show them
example of the better the game and
what's very interesting is that after a
while it can do this with a new dog he's
never seen before
it's able to exhibit superhuman
performance on a particular task so how
can we help people's life with this
[Music]
cover photo
yesterday at 10:29 p.m. this image may
contain outdoor cloud foliage planet
tree this image may contain six people
child close-up right one or more people
Jori smiling nineteen likes three
comments one now I can see the picture
in my head just like yeah you should've
been back close up like now I can say it
[Music]
the whole saying of pictures being worth
a thousand words I I think it's true but
unless you have somebody to describe it
to you even having like three words just
helps flesh out all the details that I
can't see I feel like I can fit it
there's more I can do I can just call my
mom like yeah I seen your picture in
Chevrolet what she's like how you see it
because my phone read it to me is new
I'm gonna mess with my motherhood so
much in the future we'll be able to give
a complete description of the image the
two people happy and I sad they holding
hands with one another it's this kind of
comment that a human would make with
systems in the lab they are able to do
this and there will be deployed over the
next few years artificial intelligent
systems are going to be an extension of
our brains the same way cars are an
extension of our legs they're not going
to replace us they're going to amplify
everything we do augmenting your memory
giving you instant knowledge
and they're going to allow us to
concentrate on doing things that are
properly human
[Music]
right so so said not positive trait just
claw a calculus to Castle VA a 5811 for
school we study run party discs on
superb mom pass cursive upon the the the
Yankee refreshes kimochi disease develop
or until associate a media shows Kampala
to treat as if a stigma one of the areas
that I'm you know III think is gonna be
very transformative is how we interact
with computers when computers not only
understand the speech and and transform
it into words but really understand what
those words mean and can act accordingly
the way we we deal with with computers
with machines in general is going to be
completely transformed and it's not just
go influence us in enriched societies
but all over the world because once you
have the recipe for this you know it be
used for very cheap anywhere and and
similarly I think we're going to have
amazing effects on society through the
changes in healthcare so what do I mean
by this what what these machine learning
algorithm can do if we provide them with
the data the data actually exists just
needs to be put together in you know
centralized is the ability for computers
to interpret your medical information
and help doctors take much better
informed decisions right now for example
we're collecting these genomic
information 2.5 million base pairs for
example and a doctor can't look at all
of these things to figure out you know
what's the best treatment for you so we
need computers to help us and predict
with the the best treatment or our set
of treatments for you another area which
you've heard about is self-driving cars
and robots in general all of these
heavily used deep learning
now it's mostly for the computer vision
but also for taking decisions and
planning and so on in the future even
more than it is now so as I said these
are just the things we can envision
right now but I'm sure people following
us will will have you know ideas for
things we're not even thinking of right
now
Thanks merci au choix there are three
key words at CFR that define what we are
excellence global and impact and you see
what we mean by this and the talks
tonight quite a bit and all the decides
desire three Servite Michalik the McGill
wiki Casspi Howard Webster foundation
fellow as if are a direct result of any
of the program the cosmology a gravity
any professor a McGill Danka department
the physic well he shares Canada a shire
Lorne trotty Missy horn pull the spout
to row many of us have been quite proud
last October that Canada got a Nobel
Prize in Physics art McDonald has been
associated with CFR for decades we have
all heard and we we have all been
fascinated by the story on gravitational
wave just small number of weeks ago
there are some c4 fellows that are
centrally involved in this story the bio
of Vicki is like a poem
when you read this right
Herzberg meadow
steezy prize Killam prize pizza Quebec
Mary victory but he was eligible
Petersburg the top cover canada-us
Young's
apamea fam are going either Petersburg
may be Nobel Sunday who knows
no pressure Vicki Vicki can't be sitting
gone pleaseö deadly ce soir je vais vous
parlez during the occasional news
article don't not program this if our
Kelly lat
Sheila gravity what is the nature of
gravity now you know a lot of us think
we know about gravity so what makes
things fall so it makes you get down the
ski hill but you know really physical
understanding of gravity first came from
this gentleman here Isaac Newton way
back when hundreds of years ago and we
all know the story of him sitting under
the Apple getting hit by an apple and
suddenly realizing oh it's gravity but
what is what was that really about what
was it was about and the reason that you
know the theory if his gravity theory
was called you know universal law of
gravitation you nivel cell was because
what he put together was that the
falling of that Apple was telling us
something very important about the
reason we have planets in orbit two
totally different ideas he connected
them he realized with his cannon analogy
that if you fire the cannon yes the
cannon ball will eventually fall in if
you fire it harder the cannon ball will
fly even further but if you fire it
really hard and well it's circle it will
go all the way around and keep falling
and falling and falling in what we call
an orbit and it was this realization
that puts you know everyday objects
together with the cosmos and
explains why planets in orbit around the
Sun and this was our understanding of
gravity you know really until the 20th
century there's a classical picture
beautiful in many ways but doesn't
answer really simple questions like why
what is this magic property of large
masses that makes things fall toward
them why simple kid question and really
you know this classical picture of and
mathematically fairly simple theory of
Newton it was displaced revolution
occurred in gravity in the 20th century
thanks to Albert Einstein got
mathematically a little bit more
complicated but he introduced the idea
of relativistic dynamics objects moving
relativistically and what does that mean
what he explained was that gravity the
reason things seemed to fall was purely
geometric he envisioned space-time as
malleable deformable here it's
represented by this two-dimensional
surface these lines that you see that
are being deformed by mass in his
picture and his understanding mass
deforms space-time and he saw space is
something you could stretch and time as
part of that that's what the relativity
is about that you could stretch
space-time and that's exactly what mass
does it made gravity be something that
is intimately entwined with geometry and
this picture this different explanation
you know it's been around for you know
since he he postulated it and yes you
know person of the century Wow
but in science and I feel really
strongly about this it's not about being
a rock star it's about being right and
about being empirically verifiable and
so we don't just accept because he has
great you know he looks looks amazing
and a brilliant theories in principle
you have to test them and so we ask the
question was Einstein right we do
experiments to verify his theory and
even nowadays we're going
that we're asking can we go beyond
Einstein can we understand gravity at a
level that that even he didn't quite
understand that's part of our gravity
and cosmology program can we unify it
with other fundamental forces and I
think that he would have been thrilled
he would have loved to see the sort of
work that we're doing and see far he was
somebody who who really enjoyed this
interchange between experimentalists and
theorists and just after dinner I have
to show you this I don't have anybody
recognize that that's the Hollywood
actor John Malkovich being Einstein and
I just I ran into that on the accident
on the internet and I just had to show
it to you I thought was so funny now
testing models of relativistic gravity
this is what we do this is what we want
to do we want to was he right now in the
solar system in any environment that
you're used to the effects of general
relativity are so tiny they're minut
they're tiny perturbations on on the
physical on the physical laws that
Newton's saw so yes when he was alive
there were tests of general relativity
but there were all really difficult
experiment difficult things to see in to
measure tiny little effect but today we
know of parts of the universe where we
can test general relativity where it
really matters where Newton's classical
dynamics breaks down very very quickly
and we feel that if you're going to
believe in this theory you would better
test it where it really matters and this
two environments that we know of that
are observational e accessible one the
first one I hope you can see it says
neutron stars and that's the area
research that I do and some of my
colleagues in C far do and those have
been observable now for since 1967
really and the others black holes and
those are just starting to become truly
observable I'm gonna tell you about both
of them so first of all neutron stars so
neutron stars and there's that's
actually a little movie that would be
good if we could start that up so
neutron stars these are
that's oh this this type of neutral
starts called a radio pulsar a pulsar
this is not a star that is just shining
with it you could see with your eyes
it's a star that is rotating in this
case about an axis that's vertical and
that has two bright beams coming out of
its magnetic poles and these are like
cosmic lighthouses
so each time one of these stars rotates
that beam flashes toward Earth and we
receive a burst a pulse of light and
actually unfortunately these types of
stars these radio pulse are as a form of
neutron star they're really compact
they're only about 20 kilometers across
and at interstellar distances the
distance of the galaxies these things
are way too small for any telescope to
be able to resolve so I have to show you
only a cartoon so I'm sorry about that
but that's the what that's what we
understand is going on but what you see
it so we can't actually see these
neutron stars in this way what we see is
the light from them turning on and
turning off so what we actually detect
this is the light coming on and off on
and off over and over and over again and
in the bottom slide I'm showing you some
actual data from a telescope where you
can see many many of these pulses this
is what we observe we digitize it with
computers we record it and we analyze it
and it with sophisticated algorithms now
what are these objects what are these
neutron stars so we call them cosmic
lighthouses and what they represent what
they are is some very massive stars so
about 40% more massive than our Sun and
in case that's not intuitive enough for
you because not a lot of people are
familiar with the mass of the Sun is but
if you could take five hundred thousand
planet Earth's okay and take all that
matter and crush it into a sphere of
diameter 20 kilometers so five hundred
thousand earths crushed into 20
kilometres and you'd understand and this
is a very very dense object so the
density here is sec is the highest in
the universe that you can actually
realize apart from in a black
and yet we can observe these objects we
know of 2500 them around the sky this is
something that we're doing a lot of and
you can imagine that this is a very high
density so if you could go up to a
neutron star and I don't recommend this
but if you could go up with a
teaspoonful and to scoop a little bit of
a neutron star it would weigh a billion
tons so this is not like matter that
we're used to here on earth it's not
matter we can ever hope to produce in a
terrestrial laboratory and in fact the
nature of this kind of matter ultra high
densities is really unknown to currently
to physicists it's one of the
interesting questions how what how does
matter behave under those extreme
circumstances and if those things aren't
you know exotic and weird enough for you
some of them rotate and really really
rapidly for the one I'm showing you here
is pretty slow but the fastest one we
know of which by the way was discovered
on supercomputers at McGill University
by my research group rotates 716 times
per second so just it's hard to imagine
that it's faster than your blender
faster than the kitchen blender and and
I should also say these objects for some
quirk of nature we don't fully
understand are most easily observed not
with optical telescopes that you could
hope to look through but with radio
telescopes and so the data that I'm
showing you is actually radio waves from
outer space detected using large radio
telescopes and here are some of the
pictures of the radio telescopes that we
use on the left there that's the Green
Bank radio telescope in West Virginia
that's a hundred meter aperture that's
two buses down there in a building just
for scale another one that we use is the
Arecibo telescope in Puerto Rico it's
300 meters across this is a three-story
building over here that's a three-story
building and that's a catwalk you can
walk up if you're crazy enough to do it
which we were and here's actually a
picture of us somewhere at the top of
the feed structure there's several
hundred feet above the surface and some
people ask me is it scary to do that and
the answer is yes terrifying but this
kind of science with these radio
telescopes we sampled the data very very
rapidly collect huge data sets and then
cart them off to supercomputer centers
and major neutron star searches that
we're doing currently at these radio
telescopes are being processed on
compute canada supercomputers including
the gilman one located at McGill
University as part of this sort of
science we collect heute when I say huge
it the search with Puerto Rico is we're
collecting a total of 1 petabyte of data
so this kind of science also has a lot
of applications for big data management
data visualization and sophisticated
efficient computer algorithms now I
brought with me a few just to get you in
the spirit of this - how to understand
how fast these things are rotating some
sounds from pulsars
the first one is a slow pulsar and you
can go ahead and make that sound so you
take the output of a radio telescope
this radio waves
amplify it and plug it into a speaker
and you can hear the sound of the pulsar
about 0.7 seconds and each one of those
in the rotation
each of these toilets
that's a typical one now the next one's
a little faster that's 11 rotations per
second
period
is very very sick
and the last one this is one of the
fastest rotators and now it's an audio
range
all sorts provide that spectacular
now one thing I want to say is that I'm
hiding from you an important fact about
these objects which is why I want
Wehling on them so much is that this the
time between pulses this is this period
that we talk about the time between
successive pulses it actually can be
measured with extreme precision so that
the period of this pulse are the time
between these pulses it's actually this
value here with 15 decimal places and
the number in brackets at the at the end
here is the uncertainty is the error bar
on the last digit okay now this it's you
have a very heavy object that loves to
rotate it's hard to make it diggle
around
it's an incredible clock you have this
fantastic clock at interstellar
distances this allows you to do
spectacular physics experiments that
lets us test all sorts of things about
gravity and so sometimes one of the
beautiful things about doing searches
you find amazing objects you find binary
pulsar so that's a pulsar orbiting
another star and if you start up this
movie you're going to see first of all
this is a movie of a double pulsar
binary we know one of those we have two
pulsars orbiting each other and in this
case they're orbiting every 2.4 hours so
you think about the earth going around
the Sun once a year these things are
orbiting each other really really fast
once every 2 and 1/2 hours and because
there's such perfect clocks we can
observe these pulses with great
precision and measure very rapidly
deviations from Newton's from Newton's
law and test Einstein's theory of
general relativity and even test
alternative theories to gravity because
there we don't you know general
relativity isn't the only isn't the only
one out there most of these binary
pulsars are not double pulsars earth so
there's a neutron star a pulsar and some
other star and here's where we come to
gravitational waves you know if you
think about a binary pulsar system and
here you see the binary and this the
magic green grid that you have there
that's showing the destroyer
of space-time that's predicted in
general relativity by Einstein you see
that they if the binary is stationary
you have the same distortion where the
mass is but then and if you go ahead and
start the movie as you have these things
orbiting each other that distortion is
constantly changing space-time and that
those changes get propagated outward and
that's what we mean by gravitational
waves so what you heard all about LIGO
and about the detection of a double
black hole system you're talking about
it about in a second the point is you
have motion of very heavy objects
distorting the fabric of space-time
repeatedly over and over again and
sending out gravitational waves which
actually remove the energy from the
binary system so it causes those two
objects to coalesce eventually and the
first measurement of this sort of
coalescence are not the coalescence but
the leading to it was actually awarded a
Nobel Prize to Joseph Taylor in 1993
that was my PhD supervisor and what he
measured was the decay of an orbit of a
binary pulsar system you can see the
data points they're perfectly following
general activity if Newton were right
they would have lined up on this line
here so totally you know totally huge
huge effect that error bars they were
included so now fast forwards that that
was back in 1993 the Nobel Prize for
verifying Einstein and seeing that
there's gravitational waves indirectly
by seeing the decay of an orbit but not
detecting those gravitational waves
directly and it took until now 2016 to
actually be able to measure those
gravitational waves directly with LIGO
the laser interferometric gravitational
wave Observatory to interferometers with
powerful lasers one located in
Livingston Louisiana and the other
across the continent in Hanford
Washington and very sophisticated
instruments and we're very proud to have
CFR members also involved in this kind
of project uh what they detected as you
all heard about work
black holes coalescing something that
you could never hope to observe with any
telescope there must be lots of these
things going on in the universe but they
don't produce any light and so this is
sort of a this is a computer simulation
of these two black holes you can see the
distortions in space-time cause the
strange phenomenon around them of sort
of we call it gravitational lensing of
the background stars and what you can
see is the actual data here from the two
LIGO observatories one in Louisiana and
one in one in Washington with this
characteristic signal exactly what you
expect and exactly as predicted by
Cirrus and in fact from that signal the
exact same signal across the continent
you can measure the masses of those two
black holes and you know there's one
thing it's wonderful to be testing these
these kinds of advanced theories but
it's also really beautiful to be able to
communicate this kind of science to the
public we have here you there was quite
a bit of press around this and one of
the movies appeared that in the New York
Times was actually made by members of C
for collaboration these are coalescing
black holes you can see again the
distortion of space-time and there
they've coalesced into a single black
hole now one of the next frontiers and
this is where you know neutron star is
now merged with the sort of science that
LIGO is doing what we believe the next
sort of source that LIGO is going to be
able to detect maybe they'll detect lots
more merging black holes but another
thing they could detect is a neutron
star merging with a black hole and this
would be really spectacular because you
have mattered their black hole there's
no matter it's a very clean system if
you take a real hard object like a
neutron star and you merge it with a
black hole you have matter there that
can then produce light that you could
observe not only with logo but then also
with the telescope and learn so much
about that matter so I said we don't
really know the nature of matter at
these extreme densities and neutron
stars well here's a brand new way to
understand that kind of matter by
detecting emerging a neutron star black
hole system
and then simultaneously observing it
with a regular kind of telescope like a
radio telescope or an optical telescope
and this is a movie and you can start
the movie a simulation done by swoop
slice let's go back to that oh it's over
here anyway yeah it's a simulation being
done of a neutron star
just before merger with a black hole
where the neutron star gets tidally
shredded by the black hole and all that
unbelievably high density matter gets
spread out and we're predicting and
trying to calculate now what the optical
or radio or x-ray signature of this will
be and we will try and observe it with
other telescope that's something we're
working hard on in the in the c4 program
and just the last thing I thought I'd
mention is that we is another connection
between all these topics the pulsars
that we have been studying to test
general relativity can also be used as
detectors of gravitational waves so
there's many different ways that these
things can happen to see if our program
is so wonderful for bringing so many
different people together but the idea
here is that using radio telescopes
around the world we can observe many
many pulsars in the sky and detect
gravitational waves that we think are
passing that theorists are predicting or
passing through our galaxy at all times
and look for changes in the clock like
behavior of these different neutron
stars so and we look for correlations on
the sky so some clocks are moving a
little slower than other clocks by
comparing the clock like behavior of all
this ensemble of neutron stars around
the sky we're hoping to detect
gravitational waves in this case not
from regular merging black holes like
Legos doing but from merging
supermassive black holes and you say
what's a supermassive black hole that's
kind of scary sounding well it turns out
every single galaxy in the universe
contains a supermassive black hole the
Milky Way our own galaxy has a
supermassive black hole at its center
and when these supermassive black holes
happen to meet when galaxies happen to
collide and this happens all the time in
the universe
those supermassive black holes will
merge and
reduce gravitational waves and so this
is a movie of two galaxies each with its
own supermassive black hole at its heart
about to merge whoops
over here it's merging this one's as
well okay so here come those galaxies
and shortly we're gonna zoom into the
centers where those masked supermassive
black holes are and there's our familiar
green grid to show the distortion of
space-time due to that huge amount of
matter a billion solar masses and as
they orbit each other as they collide
gravitational waves get propagated
throughout the universe and you're gonna
see it's movies running a little slow
but so these gravitational waves move
outward they propagate throughout the
universe except in this movie they're
being beamed directly at the Milky Way
which is silly
but anyway and they arrive here on earth
so these giant radio telescopes can
observe the Pulsar and as space-time is
distorted by the gravitational waves
from supermassive black holes we are
hoping we haven't done this yeah but
this is one of the projects we're
working on that will see the deviations
in the ticks of the Pulsar clocks around
the sky and be able to infer the
presence of those merging supermassive
black holes radio pulsar timing tomorrow
thanks to the CFR program we've been
able to bring together researchers from
around the world and one of the most
exciting projects in radio astronomy
today it's going to be fantastic
for detection of gravitational waves
through this method that I've just
described it's wonderful to protesting
general relativity using relativistic
binaries it's the chyme radio telescope
that we're building in Penticton British
Columbia we receive large grants from
the Canada Foundation for innovation and
that might not look like a radio
telescope to you but it's a very clever
geometry for a telescope unlike a
circular telescope that I showed you
which can look at a tiny piece of the
sky at once in this geometry you can
look at a huge swath of the sky at once
and so just to set the scale here that's
a hundred meter
by 80 meters so this thing has an area
of six six hockey arenas and in fact
this is a picture of our team standing
in the axis of these different cylinders
you can see them here this for scale and
the idea here is these reflectors are
going to bounce radio waves from the sky
up on to the axes which are going to be
populated with 2048 antennas 2048
antennas and all of those signals are
going to be combined together and
processed in order to make images of the
sky and also study very rapid variations
in the sky in radio waves and if you
calculate what this data rate for this
kiss telescope is you realize it's not
just a telescope it's a sand box for
testing very high-speed digital digital
signal processing 1.6 terabytes per
second of data are going to be flowing
through these antennas and into our
supercomputer to process that that
exceeds the global data rate for mobile
phones so all in one place here in
Canada is a very creative kind of
telescope in fact we're we were actually
used as advertising for AMD for their
GPUs that we're going to be purchasing
to build the supercomputer out in
Penticton and anyway since it's a close
I've given you a flavor for some of the
big questions that we're attacking in
our cosmology and gravity programs part
of C far I've only had time to touch on
a few of them but the CFR program has
been really central to this kind of
advanced research that also has some
pretty significant technical spin-offs
and so thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
well now you know why we're so
passionate about safar every time I
attend one of these presentations I feel
that it's very stimulating it's very
humbling scary and I'm gonna go to bed
tonight again I'm gonna have a hard time
going to sleep I'm gonna see all sorts
of black holes and my iphone will be
talking to me so I need my glasses okay
so well I want to take all our speakers
for those fascinating talk fascinating
Thaksin one of the most rewarding things
about being part of safar is the chance
to be exposed to our fellows
cutting-edge science the questions they
are answering questions about the nature
of the universe about artificial
intelligence about harnessing
superconductivity and more not only
teach us about the world but are also
helping us to make the world a better
place
dispatcher prescribes a Viet anh Jesus
was a to see a progeny chemistry
trophies aku has a packed space Alika ah
that's the marketing point the rain
amount that I come noted dunnottar
delica a Pinilla sacred Sawa Camilla
martini Alan say Gosselaar generously en
Fattah Calatrava Delacroix possible own
of regular Irma vamanos Cirque de Savoie
la carretera de la Valliere
Internacional tonight's video dica
cassava comedy normal mrs. Dabney Merv
wahoo jealousy a to represent a radical
the knowledge circle members regularly
receive opportunities to engage with
safar talented international researchers
so please talk to me or anyone from
safar about how to become a member
mcaren fois je vous remercie levitt
presents' Oswald respected as well he
was a plutonic my Volvo good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]